Sáng ngày 14 năm, chúng tâm phục vụ hành chính công thành phố Hanoi, vũ ở với 8.3 mỡ,
Khai Trường Mohing, dịch vụ công liều động tại nhà văn hóa thôn đôi dùng xa mỡ đất,
mà đầu cho trối hoạt động mới, nhằm lưa thủ tục hành chính đến tận cơ sở.
Sẽ dịch vụ công liều động sẽ phục vụ người dân từ tắm dở đến mùi một giờ cùng hài.
Đây là chuyến xe mở màn cho chương trình Thí điểm của Hanoi,
giữa kiến được chín khai đi ki một lến 2 chuyến một toàn tại yêu địa bàn.
Đặc biệt là khu dân cự xa chúng tâm, chương học, chờ hoặc nhà văn hòa thôn.
Theo lãnh đạo chúng tâm phục vụ hành chính công thành phố Hanoi,
dịch vụ công liều động là một trong 2 mũ hình mới đang được thành phố chín 2 tí điểm,
sau hành công điểm phục vụ hành chính công cộng đồng.
Mục tiêu của mô hình là giúp nắn khoảng cách phục vụ giữ chính quyền và người dân,
giúp mọi người dân, giù ở vùng xa, vấn có thể tiếp cật bình đảng với các dịch vụ công của thủ đồ.
Chien xe, người dân được hướng dẫn và nộ phố xe hành chính trực tiếp,
thông qua hệ thống công nghệ số hiện đại.
Sẽ được chăng bị đầy đủ thiết bị công nghệ,
mặc internet, mấy quất tại liệu, hệ thống thành phố an chực tuyến
và phần mềm đồng bộ xứ liệu.
Người dân có thể đang kỹ định dành định từ VNID,
trước kỹ số, thành phố an phí dịch vụ qua kinh số,
và nhận kết quả qua biểu chính công nghệ.
Ngoài ra, các dịch vụ từ vẫn pháp liên phí và hướng dẫn kỹ năng số,
cũng được chình 2 ngày tại diệm vụ vụ vụ,
có phần nâng cao năng lực số và nhận thức pháp luận trong người dân nông thôn,
ngọt lối tưởng thường gặp yếu khó khăn,
khi tiếp cận các thủ tục trực tuyến.